[Music]
good morning to North America and good
evening to into Europe in the west of
the world welcome everyone to the
webinar data science and practice across
three industries presented by simply
learn I am your host Stewart Creek a
marketing manager here it's your
presenter today the thought leader in
data science Ronald a bit more about him
in a moment but first a few notes on how
to participate in the webinar and the
controls at the bottom of your screen
the speech bubble calls up the chat
window I see a few of you have already
spent ur messages for host and presenter
and remember to hit Send and somebody
will try to respond during the
presentation you should also use the Q&A
function and that's either the button
that has the question mark in it or the
three dots button to the right of that
which will pull up a little menu that
says Q&A that'll let you ask questions
we will gather an answer at the Q&A
portion at the end of the presentation
so we'll also be doing some interactive
polling during the webinar for a few
times let's start with a two question
hole having a technical difficulty I'm
going to come back to the poll in a
moment let me first introduce him raul
van Lew ronald is one of the foremost
thought leaders in data science and
digital transformation Nick by analytic
is the world's number one influencer
data analytics automation in the future
of the economy with respect to
technology author eating big data and
data science sites including data flow
and buta science central and he is an
advisory board member to simply learn
welcome Ronald Thank You Stuart
thank you for the kind introduction the
kind words and today let's discuss data
science in three different industry and
the short overview from from what we're
going to cover so after a brief overview
of each sector will dive into just how
data science is leveraged in that
specific sector
but also the role of the data scientist
and when we'll cover some use cases to
give you a picture where data science is
generating the biggest impact so the
need for data science has to become so
great that it's created an industry-wide
data science vacuum I think that's how
we can call it and organizations that
are really struggling to find the talent
they need to get the insights they
really want and there's a particular
strong demand for data science in three
different industries and the first one
is manufacturing so manufacturing
industry has become increasingly reliant
on robotics and on automation and the
amplification of AI in the city making
and the proliferation of the
technologies into almost every process
has prompted the fourth Industrial
Revolution and also called as the
industry 4.0 and next we delve into the
customer service industry so companies
in this industry are in a perpetual
battle who can offer the best and the
most relevant and the most compelling
customer experience so customers aren't
willing to settle anymore and their
brand loyalty is harder to come by year
by year by year and there's a race to
adopt and innovate with technology steps
can help companies in customer service
to come up with more customization with
immersion with real-time solutions but
also to come up with unique services and
on the other hand they still need to
make good profits and finally we'll
explore also the financial industry and
I think that's something that everybody
likes to hear what I'm going to say now
that there's an opportunity that some
data scientists even make a seven-figure
salary in this industry indoors - is an
industry that has been showing a real
eagerness for innovation and there's a
lot of early adoption in the data
transformation trends and the disrupting
technologies and finance and in the end
will follow all with this with the QA so
you can ask questions all the time and
we will answer them later on
so let's look to manufacturing
manufacturing has been hit on all sides
by the transformative trends and all the
technologies you can think about
robotics but also automation
smart manufacturing spurts this fourth
Industrial Revolution and as I mentioned
some people call it industry 4.0 and I
think there's already some kind of crisp
of giving away to the industry 5.0 with
all the new developments if we look to a
li and machine only they're creating
intelligent machines it'll generate an
incredible new degrees of efficiency and
productivity that impact the entire
process and the entire supply chain
manufacturing it faces continual
disruption from cost volatility but also
from policy decisions and also the needs
for more operational agility companies
within this industry also face pressures
because of the needs to digitize the
value chains with AI with cloud
computing with advanced analytics and
with robotics for more transparency in
quicker responsiveness in their
operation based on this continually
changing markets and is precious from
this market so what we see is that
manufacturers are also dealing with
other major competitive challenges like
the need to transition to sustainability
to renewable energies to be energy
savings
another new trends is 5g 5g is now
playing a greater role in manufacturing
as well as manufacturers are seeing
these big benefits in this technology in
creating smart manufacturing and
creating ecosystems of manufacturing and
this lower latency that 5g has and this
higher bandwidth means that
manufacturers can increase the use of
applications and processes like sensors
but also like centralized tracking and
on top of this all we have also AR and
VR augmented reality virtual reality and
digital printing enter the industry and
offering less expensive options for
things like prototyping or save for
training and faster training but the
question is how is data science
leveraged in this industry data science
is an important part of industrial
manufacturing 4.0 and it has the IOT
technologies it has the digitalization
the generate massive amounts of data in
this form of audio in the form of images
and sensors text and includes both
unstructured and structured type of data
all of this is coming from many
different diverse or
and production equipment from drones
from from data sources companies must
leverage this machine learning the miss
levels the AI the data mining the
process mining and the predictive
analytics to gain this competitive edge
and to increase their production
efficiencies let's dive into this
predictive maintenance first few use
cases which data science is being
leveraged across this manufacturing
industry starting with this predictive
maintenance is well I was at a recent
industry event this was I think half a
year ago I spoke with the head of
digital development for a leading mining
and Rock technology company which was in
Sweden and she told me about the
importance for them for predictive
maintenance in their operations and
we're talking about mining it's more
traditional it can't be I think when one
of their products breaks down it stops
the entire flow of their operation and
this can cost really millions of dollars
so predicting failures to prepare for
service stops is a big money-saving
asset for them it's critical in their
business companies like this use
predictive analytics and AI to identify
failures and potential risk before it
even occurs and it prevents delays in
production they prevent inventory
overproduction they avoid catastrophic
equipment shutdowns and they detects all
kind of anomalies to prevent this and
needless to say I think predictive
analytics is becoming a really powerful
tool in helping manufacturing to plan
for repairs and to schedule parts and
for replacements but also to perform
maintenance in advance of the issues
it's greatly improvement of the safety
for the human workers as well if we can
predict it what's in the role of data
science again data science analyzes and
find the solutions to these particular
predictive issues if we look to cloud
plug architects and cloud developers
they are required for entrance solutions
and if we look to machine learning
algorithms they are developed for
anomaly detection and correlation and
testing and creating regression models
that forecast the AR ùl the remaining
useful lifetime values for the
industrial parts and for the equipment
we also have the classification models
that are developed for failure
prediction
and this depending on this highly
specific timeframes
lastly predictive maintenance is
revolutionising I think how many factors
operates and it's up to the data
scientists to help pave the way for more
successful outcomes in this industry
that's the first part I think in the
manufacturing the second part is supply
chain management I want to talk about
supply chain management it covers
everything from product developments and
sourcing raw materials to distribution
and to collecting the data these
processes required to feed AI and to
feed the machine learning algorithms so
the supply chains are complicated and
predictable look at the coronavirus
right now totally not predictable
anymore and there's a lot of associate
at risk with this epidemic diseases but
all different kinds of risk out there as
well
Automation and digitalization
advancements they are resulting in
faster lead times they are resulting in
lowering inventory over production but
also automating the demands for
forecasting capabilities and reducing
the time it takes to produce and to ship
the goods everybody wants to have its
goods fast if you order something
this gives manufacturers a score of
advantages like more agility and more
predictability in the supply chains
which turns increase their profits
it also offers value lines for
sustainability which as I mentioned
airily is main challenge for and a main
competitive advantage for manufacturing
today if we look to the role of data
science again data science give
manufacturers real strategic benefits
and real value it requires the use of
real-time analytics and big data to help
manufacturers to develop contingency
plans to anticipate and to manage risk
but also to identify viable suppliers so
in every aspects of the supply chain
it also lets manufacturers dis rip very
specific supply chain functions like
procurement or like distribution data
scientists they can solve a lot of
challenges manufacturers typically face
whether it's reducing the impact of
global sourcing has on the environment
but also decreasing the life cycles for
the products or use
the blockchain to enhance the visibility
in the response time companies who want
to gain strategic advantage across their
supply chains they're looking for
engineers and for supply chain analysts
so the demand for this type of expertise
is very high in this type of area let's
move to robotics technology whose I
think exciting innovation and
application and I've been able to
witness in inaction its many of the
several global events that I attend last
couple of years and one occasion I spoke
with a research team from the Technical
University at Munich and they have
developed robotics for insertion look
very simple it's an act and seems basic
for the for the humans because it's just
inserting an item in a hole but in fact
a very difficult task for robotics these
robots are using machine learning to
figure out the insertion problem with no
prior knowledge of what to do so there's
no instructions and they use trial and
error you solve this problem and have
the item inserted in a hole they've
developed as a solution is dynamic
manufacturing environments and many
industrial machines are limited to
confines but these type of robotics are
an answer real-world environments that
really call for depth ability all the
time so advancement in these type of
robotics are improving human safety in
manufacturing because it can handle many
routine tasks that might put work at
risk and it also can increase the
demands for responsiveness and optimize
things like like assembly lines what's
the role of data science the science is
applied in numerous areas of robotics
chignon is used to develop new data
patterns for labeled data for example
reinforcement learning teaches robots to
do certain actions depending on the
industrial environment just like
insertion the insertion robots that I
mentioned inserting in in a hole and
this is a great time I think to be
working in this domain because if you
look too robotic engineer jobs and the
skills they have increased with more
than 40% over the past four years so
this is a good area to be in as a data
scientist
another aspect I think that's used a lot
in manufacturing is computer vision and
machine vision
computer vision and machine vision are
our next use case in manufacturing and
they're used for applications like
quality control and to improve the labor
cost I spoke with a CEO of an emerging
company and this was I think two three
months ago and they're using computer
vision in drones to inspect massive
blades on the turbines the wind turbines
for cracks and for floors and you can
imagine when they did this manually it
took about six hours you need to climb
in the turbine you need to inspect it
that needs to be on hold and now they're
using technology to let them cut this
process down to 34 seconds doing it with
drones and computer vision now both
computer vision and machine vision they
speed up the processing rates and
they're also constantly available to
help humans to operate to perform this
type of task and they become an integral
part in the manufacturing domain
nowadays computer vision AI to capture
the images and analyze situation and
also take action if required and it's
widely used in manufacturing for product
inspection to help find this limit
defects or today as this computer vision
has a 99% accuracy rate which is due to
the advancement of the technology but it
will increase even more and it depends
of course on the situation and machine
vision is more limited nowadays for
repetitive tasks you can think about
this object scanning and helping to
provide motion capabilities for robotics
the role of data science in this domain
is data science is used or machine
learning algorithm developments to help
augment image capturing capabilities or
to compare quality standards and to
identify issues and think about deep
learning and scene understanding
semantic segmentation they also play a
big role with with data science for
example deep learning neural networks
that are trained to identify objects
with the images that brings us to the
next one new product design and the last
use case I'm going to discuss for the
manufacturing part
example in aerospace or an energy or
mechanical or plant engineering or in
the automotive manufacturing new product
design is augmented by factors like
predicting assembly lines and for
made-to-order manufacturing companies
that develop a specialized equipment
that develop parts that dye designs that
verifying designs that go through all
the data and that's crucial for ensuring
that the products can meet the customer
standards what's the role of the data
scientist over here this requires the
data scientist to use big data to design
the products that can offer better value
for manufacturing customers but also for
risk reduction when you're introducing
new products to the market you don't
want to have any failures that they will
be returned data management tools they
used to improve the distribution AI
machine learning is applied to forecast
the market and customer demands
manufacturers can develop products that
meet specific needs and an interesting
application for AI is the generative
design when algorithm is developed to
test solutions and to optimize products
based upon the product specifications so
let's go to the next part this is the
industry segment and this is customer
service and this is one of the most
impactful industries today because it
covers such a broad scope of domains you
can think about healthcare but also
education travel hospitality medicine
retail telco insurance and I think many
many other different types type of
industries so consumers they are the
driving they are driving this evolution
for this industry because of the needs
of an expectations are changing
consumers set the bar very high they are
used to the great companies like Amazon
like Facebook and this is the new bar
they are raising and they want more
personalization consumers wants
immersive experiences responsiveness
from companies but also better
integration or across all the different
type of platforms so you might have
heard before but the competition in
consumer service is high because of the
standards already set by these companies
think about Netflix and was I was
mentioning Amazon but also Apple or
Sephora all these great companies set
the bar and these companies have set a
precedence for this customized
experiences and these recommendations
and that customers have simply grown
used to everybody expects this nowadays
and they wanted from every other company
and so you're competing whatever you do
with the customer experience that these
companies are providing although they're
not even in your industry these
companies in this industry just face a
lot of challenges and pressures in
delivering always available support and
services and extreme personalization
there's a need to be one step ahead
because customers won't settle for
acceptable anymore they want exceptional
they want a great experience for
everything what they do with your
company and it assigns is giving
companies the ability to better
understand their customers but also to
skill that customer services in all the
different kind of department data give
them insights into how their customers
are thinking how they're feeling and
what they really wants from their brands
it's also allows companies to examine
how customers are interacting with their
brands organizations are coming to grips
with the fact that their ability to stay
competitive in the current market
landscape is to focus on personalized
engagement many customer service
companies are bursting with external and
internal daytime in fact Microsoft calls
this industry the king of data but
despite of all this data these companies
deal with the challenges in figuring out
which data is useful most companies only
use less than 30 percent of the data and
they also face other data related
challenges like data ownership or
customer control over the data or a lack
of channel integration and data
accessibility but also compliance is a
big big challenge for many companies and
companies need to be able to use the
data and these new technologies to
create innovative new products and new
strategies let's dive a little bit more
in detail and take one topic
personalized marketing so diving into
the customer experience centric use case
I want to start with this
like marketing and an example is
Starbucks the company that really uses
personalized marketing to their
advantage they make about 6 million a
month just from personalized ads and
rewards on their app they use a
customer's past ordering history and
location to really customize their
offering personalized marketing like
this example calls for micro
segmentation or customer segmentation
for strategy development for engagement
and utilizing this gathered data markets
can be divided into segments I think
companies coach what works best for
which segments as well as identifying
the best platform for the organization
to engage on what's the role of data
science in in this the science is used
to gather and interpreted humor data it
utilize real-time analytics and it
provides insights to consumer emotions
and to their needs
it supports the personalization of
customer journey as well as the
development of better targeted services
it also gives companies the ability to
offer only channel solutions and
integrate it with an integrated service
as well as real-time marketing
experiences so it's a great benefit to
have your data in place predictive
analytics is applied to create
identification models or to perform
predictive scoring and to automate lead
generation and fine-tune targeted
advertisement and we have sentiment
analysis
this is analytics that targets a
consumers emotional states expressed
through speech and expressed through
conversation so NLP identifies a person
stone and from what that company can
determine is how customers feel about
the interaction or how they feel about a
specific brand let's take an example
let's say a customer goes on Twitter and
mentions what you had heart where you
had a hard time with and with ordering
on a company's platform and that they
like this new design on an updated
product your brand and use sentiment
analysis to automatically identify the
type of emotion that is attached to
these type of comments so brands can
respond in certain ways and improve
their experience with your company this
can also support
organization in many ways in customer
support and if you're using NLP and it
helps agents to identify keywords to
identify phrases and customers general
disposition so if you are an angry
customer with a problem you're going to
get your issue handled quickly by a
human agent if the brands using NLP to
identify your emotional state what's
behind what's under the hood what's the
role of data signs the row of data
Sciences in this case is to develop and
opie algorithms and that can actually
understand customer emotion and the
customer content machine learning and
deep learning algorithms are created to
automate this process which may require
machine learning or deep learning
engineers to support this and to set
this up so let's move to HR facing
customer service solutions HR is another
aspect by using real-time analytics and
using predictive analytics companies can
schedule employees according to their
predicted demand and we've all been here
before where we're heading to a store
and you want to buy a new smartphone but
there are only four employees in a
crowded room of browsing customers and
it's incredible frustrating and it can
end up that you're just abandoning the
purchase and you just go away and the
same applies for online customer support
if you have to wait too long you just go
to the next shop companies prevent this
with optimized scheduling and it saves
them money in case where the revenue and
where there's true let's say support
requires customer support where they
need more people than what they
initially expected again what's the role
of data science they designs we see yet
another case of big data where it's used
that companies can take predictive
rather than reactive actions it's also
used for future casting to a model
organization that the changes and how it
impacts employee engagement also
employee development and customer
support and retention next to death
there's people analytics and this is
another data science application in this
regards and it's often combined with
machine learning and blockchain to
develop algorithms to help streamline
the process between the consumer
submitted support tickets and the HR
responsiveness
move to conversation I I to chat BOTS
and to virtual assistant use case I
think it's something that you can
probably quickly relate to many of us
associate virtual assistants with your
smartphone and customer service
industries are using these kinds of
intelligent technologies to create
amazing customer experiences for
scalable support that are always
accessible and always available they're
easy to use as self-service tools and
they're able to pass customers off to
human agents if it's really required if
he's angry or he has a very complex
issue that needs to be solved
conversational AI as it's called and
chat BOTS and virtual assistants are
having this huge momentum in the
industry right now because they are so
convenient and intuitive to use there's
some chat BOTS I think have some roots
to go before they even convenient to be
called also cost-efficient for the
business because they can handle a lot
of repetitive actions that usually drive
human personals really crazy if you have
all this repetitive tasks like answering
the same customer questions over and
over over again what's the role of data
science deep learning machine learning
AI and NLP the ads intelligence - the
books so they're able to mimic this
human conversation and interact with the
customer in a natural way these
technologies also provides deeper
customisation more engaging interaction
between brands and the customer and more
problem-solving more resolution faster
scaleable 24 hours an AI specialist and
and skilled specific data science teams
they need to be able to integrate both
the boats solutions with the company
existing technologies and the
infrastructure and manage the whole
solution throughout the lifecycle so
they have to develop these new training
models so the boat can constantly learn
from this new date and interactions and
on the other end be improved over time
these teams also have to manage the
compliance since the companies have to
be really careful about data privacy and
about data security when they're dealing
with these new customer dates and
especially I think in Europe this is
very sensitive and very important and I
expect that this will happen in the u.s.
step-by-step as well so
another case is biometric authentication
which may not seem like an obvious
customer service use case but maybe it
is companies in this industry use it to
improve their tailored recommendation
often after offers more stronger
security and they align their compliance
strategies with the ever-changing
regulatory landscape look at GD P R
which is changing all the time
currently in retail they have a strong
incentive for this biometric fingerprint
authentication to help increase security
measures for loyalty programs for
example fingerprint biometrics smart
cards has the potential to improve the
convenience and security for in-store
shopping experiences it might help to
retail us to offer more competitive
services for the customers and this is
an important supportive measures for
companies in in cyber security
capabilities as well highly complex use
case because it's involve different
types of data like the physical and the
behavioral and the different types of
authentication what's the role of data
science in this case machine learning is
used to analyze large data sets to help
improve the biometric security and to
help improve biometric performance OCR
is used to determine text and characters
you scan it which allows the system to
compare customer provided data with
existing examples of customer documents
deep neural networks they are applied
during the development of the multi
model identification systems and
numerous data scientist skills are
needed to develop the overarching
technology frameworks or these systems
I'm not sure if we're going to do a poll
right now as we had some challenges I'd
like to if we've heard of our technical
difficulties Ronald I'm going to open
that two question poll I mentioned and
the poll asks first
what is your current role are you a
developer architect project manager data
science this or other and second
question is how familiar are you or how
familiar are you with data science
the poll open for about another 30
seconds please answer both questions
before you submit if you're finishing up
so just about 10 seconds we will close
the poll we will share the poll results
momentarily all right um turns out the
bulk of you are other category however
some from each of the other disciplines
developer architect project manager day
designer and you have your data science
professionals data science most of you
would all in the category of arrested
and learning about the subject on to one
more poll before we go on to next and
this is a question here how is data
science used in your work I'll give you
a few moments to type in the answer
about a minute right in the poll close
in about 15 all right and through some
of those later
you had a section of the presentation
okay Ronald thank you very much for that
and go ahead and continue the
presentation it's an interesting to see
that there's different backgrounds from
different industries and different roles
let's dive now more into the financial
industry and what is the role of data
science in finance so finance was one of
the first known industries that actually
use data analytics to innovate and to
introduce new solutions and to new
applications and this is pretty
interesting I think because of the very
contradiction Airy to the challenges
that they are facing in many financial
institutions and in many
very traditional have a lot of legacy
systems and infrastructures which rely
on outdated and old systems and on
silent type of data so if you're a bank
that has been in business since the
early 1900 1850s Bank this old would
have thousands of hard copy of records
and files and updating all this and
migrating their systems is a huge
undertaking on the other hand despite
this it's an industry that's often
described as some kind of data hub and
where data is it's the gold for the
financial industries and the earth I
think quite a challenge there are some
daunting challenges due to here of
amount of complexity of data such as the
market data which makes it very
difficult to leverage complicated
investment opportunities on the other
hand we see the growth of new financial
platforms like automation lending and
like blockchain and they are causing a
lot of disruption so we have the FinTech
and FinTech is this rapidly growing
innovation sector today and it's going
to hugely disrupt this industry over the
next coming years and this is an
imbalance between the demand and supply
of data science talent especially I
think machine learning and blockchain is
challenging for getting the right people
because all of these vectors data
scientists are finding that these
institutions are willing to pay
sometimes
$1,000,000 in salaries to those with the
right data science skills you can
address these type of challenges and
they produce the profitable inside so
let's think in a substantial opportunity
for everybody out there if you're in the
financial industry and you're eager to
earn this type of money to find the
niche and to find the rate to help these
type of companies here's where data
science comes in recently there has been
shifts from specific finest knowledge
and skills to data science and to
analytic skills and not too long ago
most financial institutions wanted teams
with every specific financial skill set
not so much with the data science factor
and if you look to the investment
opportunity
and the insights their world really
generated if we look at financial
institutions now the financial firms and
the investment managers would rather
have data science skill sets so they can
get the leg up on the customer
management on the fraud detection on the
algorithm tre algorithmic trading risk
analysis we have real-time analytics or
kind of personalized services in retail
banking which are the hallmarks of the
financial industry today
I see additionally as well there has
been a strong adoption of automated
analytics to support its decision making
processes which call for corresponding
expertise to manage so there's also an
industry-wide demand for data scientists
with very specific skills like F
developers or machine learning
specialists or risk control managers or
compliance expert or cyber security
specialists let's take a use case fraud
detection let's say if you have to paint
much of a picture for this one since
it's willing to bet that this is the
most if not all you use in the app for
banking and the amount of these
transactions like using an app to
transfer money between accounts they're
growing substantially and this is
leading to more causes of fraud as well
like debit or credit card fraud or
insurance type of fraud fraud is always
a catch-22 something happens and the
banks need to respond to this how to
prevent this type fraud so they have
always one or two weeks
to prevent this and for financial
institutions this isn't I think the only
customer facing issue the problem can
cause massive financial losses if it
goes and traced and if it's unresolved
once again what's the role of data
science in in this case I think the
science can provide the solution with
machine learning is used to identify and
to track patterns within the trading
data and they can detect suspicious or
odd type of activities that typically
indicates that fraud is happening and
act upon this so clustering algorithms
can be developed and they can be used to
aggregate data patterns that seems to be
suspicious take another example
algorithmic trading and it looks maybe
our sounds may be complicated and
it is it's widely used in financial
services and is based on complicated
mathematical formulas and high speed
computation and it's used to develop new
trading strategies because of the
formulas can include strategic trading
varietals surrounding prices and
surrounding timing if you look at
pension funds or investment banks or
hedge funds there are just a few
examples of the financial services who
rely on this and largely because of
their trades needs to be conducted much
more quickly than a human trader is
capable so there are close to the
trading servers as well and with high
high computes trading which is supported
to make even a profit and this is often
referred as a type of black box
financial model and in this black box
financial model there isn't much of
transparency or explained ability
involved anymore and it's a trust and
also a risk type of issue if this is
happening so meaning that inputs go in
the model does its thing and the output
comes out with no explanation of how
anymore
so what's the role of data science and
you probably know or guess it wouldn't
be possible without data science
financial industry is one gathering of
data and analytics experts that define
what you are buying when you are buying
and how you're buying things big data is
used to manage this use volume of
trimming trading data and machine
learning models they are developed to
calculate and predict the future market
but if you look to to machine learning
and AI they can also use this complex
quantitative models that introduces more
this mystery to this black box model so
it's an area that can still be explored
by data scientists to bring more
explained ability and more trust in this
equation let's now move more to the
customer relationship management in the
financial industry if you look to banks
another financial institution they use
both the corporates and they use the
consumer customer as well so they have
the B to B and the B to C and customer
relationship management that's used both
in marketing it's used in digital
engagement in
lead conversion and further to digital
transformation efforts and there's
plenty of areas where customer
relationship management is used this is
one of the top three IT investment areas
for the top 300 banking and the top 300
capital market firms and this is
according to to PwC encompasses tons of
digital transactions and social media
content and this results in both of
unstructured and tons of structured
information and the data that these
instances generate is challenging itself
because there are so many different
types of data coming from many different
type of sources and many different type
of legacy systems as well so if you look
to business banks they are now competing
with the fintechs
adept at creating great personalized
digital customer experiences and I think
one of the biggest fintechs is for
example Amazon and in this business
customer context business banks are I
think at an increasing risk of getting
supplemented by these type of fintechs
in reaching corporate customers and then
offering all kinds of relevant services
so what's the role of data science so
for instance you have no SQL tools that
often use to address unstructured data
and process it with tools like MapReduce
both which require specialized data
science skills if you look in the
customer portfolio management BI tools
and predict analysis very important for
the things like at farm scoring I'm like
prioritizing collections and develop
customer risk grades also if you look to
financial institutions that utilize CRM
systems they may require a cloud
architecture to help them evolve and
manage their systems in the cloud or in
a hybrid cloud let's move on in the
financial industry to personalized
services personalized services in
finance I think are at an interesting
place right now because of its strategic
competitive advantage to be customer
focused and to offer the same kind of
tailored interactions customers expects
from any other businesses whether it's
ecommerce or whether it's a streaming
video platform and in this context of
this example the focus is on zoomer
customers banks and financial
institutions
wants to customize their service but
then totally at scale and reach the
customers that the opportune time across
any device and any platform cross device
cross-platform it's about more real time
solutions and more streamlined customer
experiences and helping bank personnel
to focus on less repetitive tasks and
have more a 360 view of their customers
looking again to role of data sides
it's a multitude of data science tools
that's come to rescue in these type of
use cases they're used to analyze
customer data and interactions and
generate insights let financial
institutions develop new service model
basically they are used to create a much
better financial experience than what
you have been used in the past the
interesting application in this regard
is NLP and speech recognition that can
provide interactive customer features
that make it more convenient for
customers to engage with banks and with
services platforms then we have smart
contracts if you look to smart contracts
they are still considered an emerging
technology and have been getting a lot
of press attention I think the last
month the last year you tale to their
connection to blockchain and I think
this is a typical area where blockchain
is useful and this is a popular industry
buzzword and it's a constant AI trends I
think for the last two years since two
or three years since blockchain became
typically and quite hot these are
developed on blockchain network and they
helped establish more reliable
transactions without third party
involvement and one example of this
application is in banks with really
well-defined ecosystems who use smart
contracts to automate multi-party
contracts they're also gaining a lot of
traction because they can improve
transparency and decision-making as a
result of the constant verification
capabilities and this type of solution
devs establish more trustworthiness and
more accuracy in the type of data
there's about 14 jobs available in every
one blockchain developer that's
available and they make about 20% more
than the other job trolls do in finance
nowadays
the role of data science in smart
contracts is particularly reboosts I
must say look to the Machine models they
are needed to boost data to date the
catalog so they the data essence
discovery process can be simplified as
well as you can look at inventory and in
profiling that is required so data and
analytics governance must be scaled by
creating these models that identified
many more quantity of data possible to
really impact the business outcomes this
outcomes that they ensure that bank can
stay compliant and they're not running
issues with data privacy or data
security on the data ownership and again
especially I think in Europe this is
very important designs also have to
collaborate with the business leaders so
the smart contracts can be applied
towards data as a chairman and improving
the analytical decision making here the
role and the communication from a data
scientist is really crucial to have this
skill there's a big needs I think for
blockchain developers who can manage the
whole blockchain application lifecycle
so or any out anyone out there
interested in this domain I think you
have a nice and a great opportunity to
dive into this domain and to be a
specialist that brings a lot of value a
lot of use case is in the industry is
cybersecurity and because of the level
of digital innovation happening in the
industry there's some eyebrow-raising
levels of risk that banks and financial
institutions have to manage and stay
ahead of like high volumes of sensitive
financial data that's constantly and
continuously being streamed being
collected being stored being processed
and being transferred and this
introduces all kinds of new
vulnerabilities and to the threat of
cyber attacks the ciphertext it's always
the challenge because you always are
behind of the new type of attack and you
need to respond to this and you have
only either a few days or maybe a week
to respond to it properly in the
financial industry the scientists have
to be able to align a final institution
cybersecurity strategy with the overall
business strategy
and they have the leadership on board
and involved in this process so they
need to be capable and able to explain
and on the other hand be trustworthy
what they explained is really the actual
situation so cybersecurity risk
management programs have to be developed
to anticipate and deal with all these
type of challenges and clouds and data
analytics they are used to accelerate
this transformation and help these
companies to manage the growth
challenges and adapt to these new
threats the digital dependency presents
but also the opportunities it has let's
look at some other type of cases I want
to touch a couple of data science roles
as well in a broader sense within the
industry before we start the closeout so
machine learning is widely used to
identify and to monitor risk across
numerous financial service applications
it also improves the cost efficiency
because it can be trained with all the
customer data that's readily available
to many financial institutions to
predictive analytics I think it's a
popular solution for the stock markets
and to get more specific peyten is used
with financial data crunching often and
it's pretty safe I think to bet that
most banks will need some form of
financial analysts some form of risk
analysts now and in in the future so
their designs I think is really alive
and very well in this industry and
there's tons of potential for even more
exciting use cases to emerge in the next
couple of years to come as this industry
evolves quickly so before we take some
questions from the audience
I want to add a few things as a short
summary I think first thanks to data
science and companies across all
industries and they are gaining a firmer
hold on the direction of the markets are
moving data science is the driver data
analytics is the driver and to find and
to deliver the products and the service
that customers want and how to align
their business strategies to the future
requirements and we only covered these
three industries where data science is
having a huge impact but every business
in every sector benefits from data size
its manufacturing
whether it's customer service whether
it's finance excellent examples how
operations are processes how personnel
and customers are positively affected by
innovations rising out of this data
science
you are the innovator of the future and
from safety improvements to sustainable
sourcing in manufacturing
personalized recommendation and better
security and customer services up to
fraud prevention up to increased
transparency in finance and data science
has a key to unlock this competitive
advantage and the stellar performance
for these companies for basically any
type of company that has data and is
data driven
I think it's a golden time for data
science and luckily for those who are
already professionals or looking into
data science professions many curious
options available but keep in mind
organizations are looking for
specialized talents as the use case have
demonstrated there's pretty much an
option or career path out there for any
type of interest so it suggests looking
into industries and in use cases that
catch your eye that are close to your
heart that you love doing and if you
love your job it goes much easier and
you dive into it and you be enthusiastic
about it and you can get things done
much easier then if you just go for the
money which is not I think the way you
should go and you have to figure out
which skills these are which type of
assets and skills you have to do and you
have to take do we want to do a last
poll yes that anger you led right into
the question here and this is which diet
the data science skills are you most
interested in learning I'll just leave
this open for a short while we can get
to a couple of questions you're allowed
to check as many as apply to you
and if you'd get your answers in we'll
close the poll in about 15 seconds
and most of you the biggest chunk of you
are interested in data analytics
followed by machine learning but there's
interest across the board so we'll talk
about that in the questions and answers
and if you'd go ahead Ronald I think
we're ready
yeah do you have some questions from the
audience yeah we actually do click look
here there's a question about the
challenges about being a data scientist
okay and what's the question there what
challenges are the data scientists face
and what the challenges are becoming I
think if you look to data scientist and
you are a problem solver
which can be a challenge to sometimes
and the other hand you have to work with
teams and so if you are good problem
solver but you cannot work with teams
that can be quite a challenge on the
other hand I think if you look where
data scientists spent a time on is the
data collection and the cleansing it
might be not very difficult but it's
certainly tedious and it's often still
where they decide to spend 80% of their
time I think on the other hand what is
quite a challenge is balancing these
business expectations versus to reality
so expectations are often too high to be
honest and the reality is that you have
to do a lot of trial and error and it's
hard to communicate it because the
expectations hide the budgets are
sometimes high the pressure is high and
there needs to be delivered but
sometimes if the data is not there and
the data quality is not there it's it's
very hard another part I think is to
communicating get the right data
communicating what you can deliver and
communicating what you have delivered
and I think another point is what we
discussed already a little bit about is
the ethics and the responsibility as a
data scientist move towards the industry
where AI takes more and more decisions
and where the AI should be
ethically developed and where the
question is what is ethical II because
for example in China face recognition is
accepted that everywhere where you go
there are cameras and they recognize
your face and and it's used for
detecting people checking people but if
you are in the u.s. people don't like it
so they don't think it's ethical if
you're on Europe it's far from ethical
because you have GD P R and neither
governments or organizations are allowed
to store personal information and
without having the consent so there's
multiple aspects for data scientists and
then if we look more from a broader
perspective from a company perspective
you have the culture you need to fit
within the culture and to get this
data-driven culture and to work in the
teams and you have your whole data
management infrastructure we're talking
about the financial institutions that
have a lot of legacy systems so if you
start as a data scientist how flexible
can you be which tools can you work with
how many legacy systems are you working
on everybody likes to work with newer
tools on a separate environment but
that's not often possible so it's job
with many challenges on the other many
opportunities I think right there are
several questions about different
industries from the one you covered once
you covered oil industry Hospital
telecoms you see industries that are
slower or if you look for example at
construction or Real Estate's it's
slower if you compare to telecom finance
it's a retail so some industries are
really driven by data media it's totally
crazy everything is data-driven like
like in the financial industry so you
have some loggers if you look to small
cities smart cities start using it but
it's really depending on the country and
the city
I'm so there are behind if you compare
it to media if you compare to to
financial institutions but step by step
you see it used more and more so every
industry will get into the
same direction where they are a data
analytics company where they are data
analytics service provider in the end
but for sure you have legis and you you
have innovators in different industries
and within an industry some are very
innovative so probably within the
building industry you will have very
innovative companies that create this
small buildings they are much more ahead
than other laggards which are just
building maybe with the bricks and
cement to create the houses or for the
office building so I think it depends on
one industry but also the type of
company whether it's an innovator or a
laggard another question from the person
who asked about the oil industry whether
there's an advantage in specializing
anisha's and data science or artificial
intelligence or are there other
industries or other segments that are
specialized so if you reverse the
question and you think from a company
perspective if you're a generalist and
you can do everything a little bit you
come to help the company anymore with
with this problem if you can line
industry knowledge and maybe very
specific industry knowledge that is
required whether it's a computer vision
and image recognition or labeling
certain type of algorithms for certain
industries that's specifically and yes
you can let's say look to all different
kinds of industries sometimes you can
hope from from industry to another but
the more you specialize the more
valuable it is for a customer that has
this problem so back to the question are
there different industries or niches
where you can dive into yes in every
industry you can find niches and it's
it's simply on one end look to the the
most obvious cases in each industry and
see how it can match your expertise but
also see how it makes your passion if
you love retail if you love customer
experience try to combine it if you
don't like it and you think oh that's a
good niche because I can earn a lot of
money I'm not sure if that's going to
work out so look for your knowledge and
if you don't if you
coming back just from school starts
working as an internship and and creates
this type of industry knowledge I'm
studying in the evening hours on one
hand for your data science skills for
your big data skills but also your
industry skills also your soft skills
which are helpful to develop your career
opportunities enough and I think it's
just find and ask the companies what is
your main challenge that should be
solved and think about back what is
required for this both the industry
knowledge combined with the data science
knowledge I think you touched on this
but there's several questions from an
engineering background in engineering
automation into the science if you have
anything additional to say about that
kind of transition and how so if you
loop through background on one end I
think if you look the company's company
starts looking broader and broader what
should be the backgrounds from a person
I spoke to relics also known from from
LexisNexis and they hire everybody who's
interested in the domain and has a
Bachelor degree whether it's in history
it doesn't have to be mathematics it
doesn't have to be engineering if you
have a technical background I think it's
very very helpful because you have a way
of thinking but companies look broader
and that's also from this question about
this domain expertise domain expertise
is important so you can either get
experience from the domain expertise or
you can learn the data science part if
you are domain experts dive into some
courses and of course it's good to do it
with we simply learn as well but there
you can get the expertise that you need
as a data scientist and combine it with
your industry expertise and so this way
I think you can in the end solve the
issues for for the clients that's all
the time we have for questions but I'd
like to thank Ronald for sharing his
insights with us and you can find and
follow him if you want to advance the
slide Ronald a year and
and on the next slide you can see that
simple learn is also available at simply
learned on pretty much any social
platform and please feel free to contact
us with your questions we will be
sending out a recording of our link to a
recording of the webinar and really
you're joining us today you around for
our next webinar
thanks again thank you